dame lillard has 48 wade looked at me
and said no
dame has 50. we didn't know that was
going to happen it's now time
to welcome in dame lillard aka
dame dala congratulations on an
incredible comeback win
this is adam lefkow on the nba on tnt
tuesday crew
was there anything said in a time out
anything that said in a huddle
that spurred this 25-7 comeback run dame
i mean we just kept fighting our way
back and then they hit a couple threes
and we'll call timeout we kept coming in
the huddle saying you know we're a team
that
is experienced you know we're the more
experienced ah
we kept saying we're the most
experienced team and um
you know we these are the kind of games
that we capable of winning and uh
you know we just got to stay the course
and i thought our team showed a lot of
resilience you know we showed a lot of
togetherness and
um as it seemed like it was getting
worse i felt like our communication and
our trust in each other just kept on
building especially
on the defensive end um and when we when
we put it together on a defensive end
uh you know offensively we've never had
an issue and that was when the game
turned around for us
dame a hell of a game me and my co-host
here adam lefkow we had a
three-point shootout we both went two
for 36.
so to all the little kids out there how
do you become a lethal shooter
like dame dollar because i always wanted
to ask the shooter it's like how do you
how do you get your jump shot that
deadly
i think it's just putting a lot of time
into it you know i think
we got some some great shooters in our
league you know obviously you know
we think of steph curry first when we
think of shooters the greatest shooter
to ever play in our league
um but he'll tell you the same thing
that is a lot of reps you know
whether people are watching or whether
you get credit for it or not you just
you put the time in and you do it at a
game pace uh you do it with focus
um you do it while you holding yourself
to a certain standard of you know
whereas
make 10 in a row at each spot at the end
of your workout when you're tired and
you probably don't want to do it just
things like that
over and over and over and over over the
years
and you get better from the reps but i
think more so than just physically you
get better mentally and more confident
in it because you've done it so often
you've done it when you're tired you've
done it when you didn't want to um and
then
in in the moments uh you know end of the
game whether it's first quarter second
quarter third quarter
a tough shot the easy shot um you you
got the ultimate confidence that it's
going to go in and i think confidence is
the biggest thing for shooters
um right next to just getting the reps
in and knowing in your heart
um that you didn't cheat it you know you
put the time in and you deserve to make
those shots and um
you know you expect that result you know
all that sounds good but i guarantee you
that's not going to work
for me and adam lefko hey
it's a little too late for you
[Laughter]
damn i've always been blown away
conversations we've had just in your
poise
and your your demeanor and your
leadership and your
ability to continue to do what you know
you put the time and energy in
just take me through at the end of the
game it just seems like you know
that this is your moment you know that
no matter how far you guys are down
you're always capable
of coming back so what is that like at
the end of the games
do things slow down for you i'm taking
notes over here
um i i wouldn't say the game slows down
i think once that moment comes i know
that most people get tighter in that
situation you know they
i don't want to say nervous but they
just you know they're a little bit
tighter in every situation you know they
don't want to make a mistake they don't
want to miss a shot
um and i i know that it's like that you
know so in those moments i just get more
aggressive you know i
i seek i seek things out and i try to go
after it um instead of taking a step
back i take a step forward and then
another step forward
um to try to impose myself as opposed to
you know playing it safe and worrying
about what could go wrong um
once that moment comes i'm like if it
goes wrong i'm willing to take that
blame i'm willing to shoulder whatever
somebody got to say about it and if it
goes well
you know let's go back to work and do it
again and next time it happens you know
so that's kind of my mentality instead
of
tightening up i get more aggressive and
uh you know i go for it in those
situations
dame what's up brother this is d-wade
man um
i'm gonna say what everybody in the
world is probably saying right now that
they say
after every game you play you're just a
bad dude man
and um i look at everything you do i
mean
obviously commercials hulu has last
sports you know adidas
you rap you three kids everything you do
but you still
make sure that you bring your a game
every night can you talk to the kids out
there that
want to do these things want to have the
the fame and the publicity
but the work that you put in to be great
i mean none of those none of those
things that you just named would be
possible without the work
and um you know i wasn't a highly touted
middle school player high school player
or college player you know i had to
do my work behind the scenes you know
like you did i had to earn my way
um and i didn't know that i was going to
ever get the credit for it or ever get
the results for it
so i know what it's like to be unknown
and to you know not have
the lights on you and to want to be seen
and want a scholarship to a big school
and things like that i was behind the
scenes doing the work so
i don't forget those steps that it took
for me to get here so you know even
though i
i got a family and i got all these
commercials and
you know these endorsements i don't
forget the thing that makes all of those
things possible which is the work the
discipline
um the humility the compassion you know
all of those things that i know
i bring as a person i know that's a part
of why i've been able to get a lot of
the things that i've gotten so
um if i get if i get away from doing
what got me here
i'm doing my family and everybody else
around me a disservice so i make sure
that i stay true to that first
um and the more that i do that you know
things just keep coming and um
i've gotten results from that my whole
life so it's why would i become 30 and
see the results that i got
and go away from it you know so i've
gotten stronger in those things i've
gotten more discipline i work harder i
work smarter
you know i level my people harder i do
all those things at a higher level and i
just
it just keeps improving everything else
for me a season high
50 points he adds 10 assists the
portland trail blazers move to
23 and 16. you're now tied for fifth in
the west dame congrats man thanks for
joining us
appreciate it